- Whoever's in last place,
whoever that person is,
if there was a world chart ranking,
and Sally was dead last,
she can talk.
(audience laughs and applauds)
(dramatic music)
I don't know how to get
people out of depression,
I'm just trying to change
people's perspective.
Gratitude is my fuel.
I think most people burn out
because they're looking for money.
I think people are depressed
when they don't have things into context,
they don't realize how lucky they have it,
and two, they don't feel in control.
When the game itself and the process
and gratitude is the mix of your gasoline,
you'll run forever.
I've already won.
D-Rock, this game's vigged.
I already won.
I figured myself out, I
know what makes me happy.
Nothing in the world makes me happier.
Everybody is the happiest
when they get to do
what they want to be doing.
When you get to do what
you wanna do, you've won.
I think the problem is
that people get to a place
where they don't wanna go backwards
because they get fancy, right?
They get accustomed to
a certain lifestyle,
they want certain things.
When it's about getting a
watch or buying a new home
or getting a new pair of Yeezy's,
you're finished.
And I will tell you the number one thing
that scares the fuck out of me.
- Okay.
- Nice watches and Ferraris.
And so I see a lot of people
looking for quick highs.
That is just not sustainable.
Glass half empty is a
terrible way to live life.
This is full as fuck for me.
I know exactly what to
do with what's in there.
I know exactly what the
fuck to do with this
and other people don't know what to do
with a full fucking container.
Entitlement, you're fucking entitled.
If you ever, in your life,
bought a $5 fucking coffee from Starbucks,
you are fucking soft.
Globally in the 7.7 billion people,
you're fucking fancy, you're soft.
There's 50 million people
that came from dick shit
and fucking made it, so
what the fuck's your excuse?
Both my parents were crackheads.
And?
Like, I lost my job.
My husband's beating me.
And? I'm not fucking saying
these are small things.
These are the hardest things in life.
Here's my question,
life's about alternatives
what the fuck are you gonna do about it?
Nobody has anything to complain about.
Unless you're the worst human on Earth.
In the world rankings of
humans you're 7.7 billion.
You live in a cage and
you're a slave somewhere
where nobody's looking,
because that's who that person is.
Unless you're that
person, stop complaining.
My stuff is for the complainers
who don't realize they
have time to fix it.
They just have to change their behavior.
Can't complain about your weight
if you didn't put in the work.
You may genetically dis positioned to not
have as great of a body or be as healthy,
and that's just life and that's real,
but I wasn't allowed to
complain about my health at 37.
I wasn't doing the right things.
Or you can sit at home, play fucking 2K,
and blame the world for your shortcomings.
Period.
- [Man] They don't wanna do that.
- Brother, people don't wanna work.
You know why?
It's easier to complain.
- [Man] Mentality?
- The religion baby.
Like, like.
But if you don't complain,
then you've won.
You can do it anyway you want.
Make a dollar a year,
make all the dollars in a year.
You've won,
it's not about that.
Spend every minute with your kids,
spend no minutes with your kids,
if you're happy and you don't complain,
you've won.
(dramatic music)